no vídeo de hoje eu vou abrir alguns
Packs com as figurinhas da Copa
utilizando um dos lasers mais potentes
da internet mas atenção muitas pessoas
acham que este é o laser mais potente
este aqui vamos fazer um pequeno texto
eu vou apontar o laser para espuma aqui
da mala e instantaneamente já começa a
soltar fumaça mas o mais potente Eu
também eu tenho aqui e já fiz alguns
vídeos aqui no canal com este laser Olha
essa luz é incrível
Isto é preciso ter cuidado porque assim
que ele ligar ele já liga automático
Olha isso
queima muito vamos lá tentar derreter o
agweb e só para ter a certeza se isto ou
não
a borbulhar o plástico
é que eu comprei só aleatoriamente estas
saquetas eu sei muito bem que podem sair
aqui figurinhas bastante raras e caras
até tipo Neymar Sei lá eu vou só abrir
os Packs no laser e vamos ver o que é
que nós perdemos aqui nestes Packs
estiverem o Neymar eu perdi dinheiro
porque eu vou
ter uma duas três quatro cinco seis sete
oito saquetas três dois um vai cortando
figurinhas com laser
vamos ver se isto quer faz algum efeito
Calma vou aproximar mais já está a
tentar fumaça pessoal já tá a queimar
parem só como já está a queimar o papel
eu não sei se as cartas vão resistir
sequer meu eu acho que isto vai ser tudo
estourado
Pelo menos eu tenho certeza que a
primeira figurinha tá completamente
estressada já tenho quase a certeza mas
vamos ver se as próximas vão resistir eu
não quero saber se tem aqui o Neymar eu
não quero saber se tenho aqui o Messi eu
não quero saber se tem aqui o Reinaldo
eu não quero saber nada pessoal eu vou
abrir Packs mesmo com laser eu sou
maluco mesmo só para ter a certeza que
ele vai atravessar todas as figurinhas
[Música]
Como podem ver o pessoal eu fiz um
rasgão completo pelas figurinhas
a primeira estressandou completamente
Mas vamos abrir
o meu Deus
quem é o primeiro Jonathan Williams nem
sei não faço ideia de quem é este Ok
calma antes de revelar os próximos
pessoal antes de revelar só para ter a
certeza porque eu acho que esta capinha
aqui de papel é bem resistente então só
para ter a certeza que eu atravesso
todos vamos tentar atravessar-los assim
mesmo
ao contrário se tiver Vitória ou não
também não sei quem é quem é ficou com o
pescoço queimado Olha aí atravessou o
pescoço dele mais um aqui esta também
fica com o pescoço queimado ou não Este
foi o último mais um Jonathan Ok Este
foi o primeiro pack pessoal eu acho que
não foi nada de especial né vou é fazer
um furo no meio Tá feito né um furo aqui
bem no centro
estiverem dentro do Neymar vai se
arrepender não sei eu acho que assim
elas não escapam assim Acho que vai
atravessar tudo Acho que já tá a queimar
aqui já já estou a ver aqui uma pequena
mancha não sei se dá para ver aí na
câmera mas já está atravessar aqui o
código de barras
agora faço aqui deste lado também só
para não comentarem aí a Dark Dark só tá
a queimar os primeiros não pessoal aqui
é para queimar tudo olha no mesmo ponto
ui temos aqui uma Dourada meditar em mim
temos aqui uma Dourada qualquer não sei
o que isto é mas está completamente
destruída esta esta até tem um número
aqui só esta que tem este número pessoal
Alguém sabe me responder aí nos
comentários que número é este aqui isto
deve ser para a caderneta online ou
qualquer coisa assim próximo Nicolas
mais um jogador destruído pelo laser ou
não
Este foi pela boca
Ah esse é o lugar que esse aí é poderoso
ya isso é bom isso é bom eu acho escolhe
o pé escolhe o pé
na tesoura
ou não ou não ou não
não assim tá bom Outra Dourada aqui
primeira carta mais uma Dourada Não faço
ideia do que isto é caixa para qualquer
coisa
Daniel
maximê não conheço Ui tem que ir ao
contrário tá aqui o japonês curtadíssimo
no meio Olha isso perfeito
eu acho que vai mais uma tesoura
acabou
já eu espero que não sai o Neymar mas ao
mesmo tempo eu quero que sai o Neymar
vamos ver qual é o primeiro
milos
este acho que não vale a pena mesmo este
é argentino Este é argentino
Gomes Deve ser bom também
nós cortamos o sistema do Uruguai quem é
este Rodrigo ou qualquer coisa não
conheço vamos embora e este ui também
não conheço
Andreas a única coisa amada este vídeo
do outro lado olha isso tá saindo aqui
deste lado já aqui agora eu tenho a
certeza que todas as figurinhas estão
completamente destruídas Agora sim eu
tenho a certeza bora bora primeiro quem
é este Arnold não Lord eu estou a ouvir
isto ao contrário pessoal
próximo
Gonçalo prata
Erick Max chupa o Mutinga eu acho né em
busca do Neymar legendário até agora
nada isso vai ser outro na tesoura não
conheço este não interessa
aqui Mateus qualquer coisa
Sérgio
cortado no meio quem é este aqui
também mais um pack podre né pessoal
também tem o que é que vocês acham eu
deixei passar aqui alguns jogador bom
todos os Packs estão a ser podres
comentem aí pessoal eu quero saber a
vossa opinião porque eu não percebo
assim muito futebol Ok eu confesso que
não entendo assim muito como vocês vocês
é que passam a vida aí a ver os jogos de
futebol e a jogar FIFA ou não Bora temos
aqui um espanhol ui a equipa portuguesa
é o equipamento tá aqui a equipa do
catar toda essa perna vamos aí artan
cortado no meio acho que isso é bom acho
que isto aqui é bom
até agora ainda não apareceu nenhum
português
qualquer coisa pronto mais um pack podre
temos mais um pé Se sair o Neymar aqui
não esqueçam pessoal até vai pensar que
foi de propósito Ah eu deixei o último
Pack para o fim com o Neymar
Este foi na trinca rasgadíssimo acabou
se tiver aqui o Neymar já vai com menos
uma orelha para casa
ficou sem horário
Calma já sabemos a nossa primeira
figurinha pessoal bora lá mais uma
equipa que é isto Costa Rica Ok Costa
Rica foi embora
ui
Karine mandou um abraço oi oi estamos
aqui um brasileiro temos aqui um
brasileiro
ai ai ai acho que é brasileiro pelo
menos a tu ver o equipamento Amarelo
Bora Será que é o Neymar 3 2 1 ah
Anthony é o Anthony Anthony Ok os
próximo joycipa e acabou pessoal Acabou
acabou aqui está o nosso Cemitério dos
jogadores da copa hahaha agora o lance
dos Desafios Se quiserem que eu compro
um daqueles Packs uma daquelas caixas
com 100 Packs de figurinhas da Copa e
destruir completamente a caixa comentem
aí pessoal deixem muito like que eu vou
fazer mas é o primeiro preciso de saber
se vocês querem ver esse aqui no canal e
é isso espero que tenham gostado
aproveitem também já que estão aqui no
vídeo para ver este vídeo que está
incrivelmente bom e é isso pessoal fica
bem até a próxima
[Música]